hey you guys
time for another flickers of fear my
personal movie review show
it occurred to me the other day that in
all the
time that we've had this channel one guy
that i don't think we've ever covered
you know it's long overdue that that we
did or at least i did
was uh one herschel gordon lewis uh
otherwise known as hg lewis
now if you guys don't know h.g lewis uh
was an exploitation
filmmaker he's from florida and a lot of
a lot of his uh movies were shot down
here
usually around the sarasota area he
started out i think doing kind of more
sexploitation softcore porn type of
films
but in the early 1960s he parlayed into
gore and he's pretty widely acknowledged
as the first
person to do what would now be called
splatterflix
now the first one of these and the one
that he's probably most famous for
uh came out in 1963 and it was called
blood feast
and it's basically about a guy who's
like a worshiper
of some like egyptian goddess or
something and it's
you know it's him killing people to make
this big cannibalistic
feast or whatever the titular blood
feast which makes sense
so if you see this in i can't imagine
what people in 1963 like thought of this
movie
because i really don't think yes there
had been you know proto-slasher films
you know like psycho and things like
that but it's like considering
that psycho was so shocking in 1960 and
then just three years later
you have blood feast which you know
obviously not a mainstream film it
mostly played you know in the south like
on the drive-in circuit and things like
that
but it was a huge leap forward i mean
despite
the movies being essentially
exploitation pictures they were very
very cheaply produced
you know the acting's not great the
stories weren't great but i mean he
really latched on to this
over-the-top gore just like you know
buckets of blood
and you know entrails and things like
that
and he really sort of cemented his place
in horror history i suppose
so as i said 1963 saw the release of
blood feast which was massively
successful
and then the next year he did another
one called 2000 maniacs
which is also pretty entertaining i
haven't seen it in a while
but i'll probably be doing that one
somewhere down the line
and the third one in the so-called blood
trilogy they actually called it that
later like after all the movies were
released and they kind of packaged them
all together on vhs or whatever
the third one the one that we're gonna
be talking about today came out in 1965
and is called color me blood red i will
argue as i said it's been a while i saw
a blood feast
uh for the second or third time fairly
recently
and i've seen 2000 maniacs but it's
probably been like 15 years since i've
seen it
but from what i can remember of those
two i think color me blood red is
probably
the least successful of the three it's
for sure the cheapest
i think i think it only cost about 50
grand to make
and as i mentioned earlier it was shot
around
the beaches of sarasota where they had
rented a house and pretty much the whole
thing takes place in this
one house and sort of the beach around
it that said though
there's still some there's still like
some kind of charm about this movie
that i really kind of like i can't
really explain what it is it's as i said
it's not a good movie by any church the
imagination like
the acting is bad like the score is
overbearing and super loud like the you
know the
the focus goes in and out it's just you
know it has these really really long
takes where nobody's talking and like
nothing's happening and stuff like that
it's just like this really strange
and it's short it's only like 79 minutes
long and some parts of it like feel like
it's really long
but that said i don't know there's just
something about this one i like i guess
it's maybe like the premise or whatever
even though the premise isn't super
original either because
the premise for this movie color me
blood red is
pretty much exactly the same well at
least from what i remember
from the roger corman movie a bucket of
blood which i think had dick miller in
it
i mean wasn't a bucket of blood that was
about a painter that used blood or
something like that right i mean i
thought it was if that was
indeed roger corman's uh idea for that
this is pretty much the same thing so
what you have in color me
blood red you have this dude named adam
sorg
and he's this painter and he lives with
his girlfriend gigi
in this beach house in sarasota now he
seems like he's pretty successful as an
artist
i mean it's not like he's a starvingers
he has a nice beach house and everything
and he does have
one man gallery shows and whatnot so
that's pretty successful so at the very
beginning of the movie his girlfriend's
kind of like getting on his case
because he was supposed to go to this
gallery opening and talk to his
backers or whatever so he does have
people that buy his stuff
but he still seems kind of cranky and
so he shows up there and i guess like
it's established that
even though he seems fairly financially
successful
he's not real successful with the
critics and like they kind of give him
this snotty attitude about well
you know you're kind of commercially
successful but
your use of color could use some work
evidently he's not just happy painting
stuff and having people
buy them and like you know living on
that he has to be
critically lauded as well so
he gets kind of upset about it and he's
just kind of like
fighting with his girlfriend and whatnot
so then it so happens in a very very
contrived
uh situation that he
sort of like he get in a fit he sort of
gets mad and he kind of tears up this
one canvas of this [ __ ] that he was
working on and leaves it on the floor
and there's like a nail sticking out of
it so his girlfriend comes out of the
bedroom or whatever
and instead of just like stepping on the
nail which would have been the thing
that would
normally happen she kind of leans down
and is like oh a nail and she's like oh
no i cut myself so you know what i mean
so then she gets blood all over the
canvas and when he comes out
he's like oh my god this is the color
that i always wanted because apparently
he'd never
seen blood before and didn't realize
what color it was and the funny thing
about it too is that
i mean clearly just like in a lot of
movies from this era
you know the blood is obviously temper
paint so it's just very funny to me like
in a weirdly ironic way that
his the whole premise is him using blood
for paint and then they're actually just
using paint for blood i don't know
that's just really funny to me
and also when when blood dries it turns
like kind of brown and crunchy so
i don't so this bright vibrant red that
he has going on the paintings it's just
kind of like i don't know i'm putting
way too much thought into this clearly
so he gets very excited this painting
that he's been working on he's like this
is it this is it so he kind of makes her
he's like hey let me see that finger
that you cut and then he starts like
smearing it all over
which she kind of lets him do she's like
all right fine but then after a while
she's like dude are you gonna like fill
up this whole canvas with blood because
um you know i kind of need the blood
inside my body so why don't you just use
your own damn blood
uh if you're gonna use that much of it
because i got other [ __ ] to do
so he's like well that's a capital idea
and he starts
using his own blood obviously he doesn't
get too far with it he
covers up most of the canvas but then
he's just kind of like getting woozy and
he falls asleep and everything
so pretty much from the jump uh
he he you know he has a fight with his
girlfriend and she says something like
well
you know if this is gonna if you're
gonna paint with blood then obviously
you know you can't use yours all the
time because you're gonna run out and so
you can pretty much see where this is
going he obviously starts
killing people to get their blood and
using that for paint and again pretty
predictably uh when he starts taking
these new paintings to the gallery
they're all like this is the most
brilliant painting that's ever been
painted
in the history of the world and not a
single person figures out that it's
blood
which i guess i don't know if the movie
is that
smart maybe it's some kind of supposed
to be some kind of indictment of the art
world or whatever
i'm not really sure i don't think he was
thinking about it that much he's uh
obviously i'm thinking about it way more
than he did he was just trying to make a
bloody movie about an artist who uses
who kills people and
splatters their blood all over the
canvas you know what i'm saying but yeah
so he does end up killing his girlfriend
and kind of like uses her face like he
like stabs her in the
in the face or in the head or something
that he's like using her head to like
smear blood on the canvas and everything
it's like pretty funny
and then as the uh you know as the time
goes on
more teenagers sort of fall into his
trap where it's just kind of like hey
let's go over to this
secluded area of beach right in front of
this house that we think is abandoned
even though it's really weird because
one of the girls
that ends up at his house later on like
modeling for him
that girl's mom is the same one that
keeps going to
the gallery and trying to buy his stuff
but the ironic thing is that when adam
starts painting
these paintings which are actually kind
of cool except for the second one he did
was but the first one was kind of cool
looking
although i thought it was a little much
i think you were a little over the top
that
should have like rained it in a little
but she's the same woman that
has been trying to buy his paintings but
then like when
when he starts painting with blood for
whatever reason he doesn't want
to sell them even though at one point he
gets offered like fifteen
thousand dollars which [ __ ] man this was
19 1965
that was probably like a million dollars
back then that's probably not a million
dollars but it was probably a lot
and he wouldn't take it so i don't know
if it was just because he was
getting to be like a serial killer and
it was just kind of like oh they're my
trophies or
maybe he's i don't know what his deal
was like obviously he wasn't like
thinking like a rational human being
obviously
so yeah so basically um all of these
kind of teenagers wander into his
orbit and he kills a bunch of them one
of them he kills and just kind of buries
in
the shallow sand like outside of his
beach house or whatever
and then these other kids like stumble
across it and it's just kind of like it
just kind of goes on from there so it's
not you know it's not a super
complicated story you don't even really
have to pay attention to it most of the
time
because to be honest other than the few
gore scenes
which are actually pretty good it's
mostly just blood but there's a couple
scenes where
like there's a couple out on these like
pedal
bike things that you go through i'm not
really sure what they're called but
they're like bikes but then they have
like floaty things on the side so you
can like bike
on the top of the water you guys know
what i'm talking about
so there's a couple of those and then he
has like a motorboat and he
sort of like comes at him with that and
like spears one of the dudes through the
chest or whatever and it's like they're
just bloody and then there's
kind of like chunks sticking out and
like at one point like one of the girls
he kills and
she's just hanging up on the wall and
she's got blood all over her midriff but
then there's like
kind of like intestines and he like
squeezes the intestines into the bowl
like to paint with and [ __ ] like that
so this isn't like as gory as blood
feast
i don't think it's quite as gory as 2000
maniacs i remember that being fairly
gory but it's been a long time since
i've seen it
this one just basically has maybe like
three or four
scenes where it's you know bloody and
gory
and then the rest of it is just kind of
like people wandering around
like teenagers these teenagers
who are obviously not teenagers they're
probably like in their 20s or 30s i
imagine or maybe even older
going around making like talking
inscrutably to one another in slang
and there's it's just so weird the
dialogue in this
which which h.g lewis also wrote this
movie by the way the dialogue in this is
so
so hilarious and just so so strange
i mean so at one point like when
this one couple finds this dead body
like buried
on the beach like by this dude's house
literally the first
thing the guy says when they pull like
they find a leg or whatever and they
pull like the leg out of the thing
first thing the guy says is holy bananas
he's like that's a girl's leg all right
and i was like wow
that dude's a [ __ ] observational
genius
and they don't get like they're upset
about it but they're not like
they're not like the kind of upset you
would be if you found a [ __ ] brother
dead body like
a couple inches down in the sand it's
just they're very kind of like
oh jinkies you know what i mean they
don't say that but it's just it reminds
me of that type of like scooby-doo sort
of
stuff uh so at the end like one of the
teenagers gets ticked she's gonna model
for him
and he has her like tied up because he's
like well you can't even hold your hands
up like to pose for the thing so i'm
gonna tie your thing and then he's going
to axe her to death
but then her friends come looking for
her and end up shooting the artist in
the face
at which point another irony he falls
onto a canvas and his head's all bloody
and it kind of splatters on there
and then his kind of buyer his agent or
whoever comes over and like burns the
canvas at the end and is like you know
that's his funeral pyre taking it very
very seriously
so you know it's not a technically
competent movie obviously it's better
than
like ed wood it's better than manos it's
better than that kind of stuff
but it's still got a lot of problems
with
you know the edit like i said some of
the scenes just go on or for a really
long time and
you know nothing happens um the picture
keeps going out of focus
like every now and then and uh the
dialogue is just
it's bad but it's also like really
really strange so it's like really
really entertaining like the way that
they talk it's just like really funny
the gore is like pretty well done it's
obviously fake because you know
1960s but as i said he was like really
really ahead of his time so it's crazy
to think that this came out in
1965 like with all these intestines and
gore and everything like that
and the background score holy crap man
it's like because a lot of times there's
not
a lot of dialogue going on so it's just
kind of like you know teenagers walking
around a beach and
just like where are we going to change
into our bikinis i don't know i'm going
to go over here and
just it's just like endless but the
background score is just like this crazy
like instrumental jazz kind of stuff and
it's just
so loud and it's just like really really
obnoxious
because it's just kind of like the songs
just kind of like repeat over and over
and over because i'm you know i'm not a
big fan of jazz
i like that it evokes that era but
there's so much of it in there and it's
just like assaulting you with music
it's just like so loud and it's like
really really repetitive and i just
thought that was like really funny it
just kept cracking me up like every time
i was like oh here here goes that part
of that song again
so if you're into like trash cinema and
you've never seen
any of hg lewis's movies as i said
you know it this is one of those ones
where you just kind of like sit around
you get drunk
you just watch them for the sheer like
ridiculousness of them this one is
probably the least ridiculous
of the three that he's known for um you
know blood feast probably being the most
ridiculous and also probably the goriest
that was also the first one
uh 2000 maniacs is also very funny it
was like killer rednecks or something
all i remember from that one is looks
like a dude
and putting a dude in like a spiked
barrel and like rolling him down the
hill unless i think they
they did a remake of that i think called
2001 maniacs i want to say with
robert englund in it and i've seen that
but it's been a long time since i've
seen that as well
so this one is probably like the most
restrained of the three
um and like i said it's kind of it's
also the cheapest one
but if you're really into bad cinema and
you really want to see
sort of the roots of the splatter
exploitation
sub-genre then you probably do need to
do yourself a favor and watch these
as far as i know i don't know if two
thousand maniacs is on to be but color
me blood red and blood feast are both on
there as of this recording
so you know go check them out get some
get some brews get some friends
have them all come over to your house
and
get super [ __ ] up and watch
some ridiculous h.g lewis gore movies
because you need to i mean you know if
you're a horror fan you probably should
so that will do it for this flickers of
fear and i will see you guys
on the next one bye